have you ever wondered what it would be  like to fight as a gladiator inside a  great Colosseum with thousands of fans  chanting your name well wonder no  further the developers of genital  jousting have done it again with their  ludicrously gory VR gladiator simulator  Gorn watch us use swords maces bows  nunchucks hammers Spears axes in even  our blood-soaked hands to dismember our  opponents if you'd like to see more VR  face smashing let us know in the  comments below and if you're enjoying  the carnage currently on screen consider  hitting the subscribe button  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]